faut-il vraiment se les faire
emprisonner pour connaître le prix de la
liberté et moi je le connais je suis un
évadé
est il nécessaire de perdre la vue pour
espérer des soleils disparu je les voit
briller je suis un évadé qui ne s'est
jamais laissé enchaîné ne sera jamais ce
qu'est la liberté moi oui je le sais je
suis un évadé
serge gainsbourg 1965
[Musique]
bien soufflé souffler
soufflé au fromage
bonjour madame oui comment allez vous
oui non c'est pour une émission pour lcp
s'appelle des confinait c'est tous les
vendredis à partir de 19h30
une fois par semaine pour les personnes
détenues pour les personnels
pénitentiaires et pour tous ceux qui
vivent là autour qui ne sortent plus
parce qu'ils sont confinés cette jolie
dupel la liberté à lui pèse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au sommaire au sommaire messieurs c'est
par ici le sommaire c'est par ici
messieurs le sommaire c'est par ici
voilà au sommaire aujourd'hui à cours de
cuisine deux étoiles toujours avec
thierry marx y est façon risotto
l'interview de la contrôleurs des
endroits de privation de liberté
madame adeline hazan dessus puis les
aurons un cours de sport avec un
quadruples champions de kick boxing
cyril benzaken et pour finir il revient
sur son passage en prison jérôme kerviel
soyez forts je sais que c'est compliqué
mais que la lumière au bout du tunnel
comme chaque semaine bien sûr on va
s'arrêter en prison et aujourd'hui nous
allons dans le val de marne pour
interviewer directeur de la prison de
fresnes
[Applaudissements]
bonjour j middle east bonjour alors
depuis combien de temps êtes-vous le
directeur de la maison d'arrêt de
fresnes bien écoutez moi j'ai pris mes
fonctions ici à fresnes depuis juin 2019
ça va faire un an bientôt mais c'est
quand même assez récent est ce qu'on
peut dire que vous êtes à la tête de la
pire prison de france ça effraie le
frêne est un vieux navire c'est un
établissement qui a ouvert ses portes en
1898 n'ont pas forcément été une des
structures prioritaires en terme de
rénovation mais qui avait toujours tenu
tenu le cas alors je sais pas si c'est
la pire prison de france en tout cas
c'est la prison qui était très
surpeuplée jusqu'à encore quelques temps
donc beaucoup moins de personnes
détenues ou est maintenant en raison de
la crise sanitaire
donc je sais pas si la prison la pire de
france je sais que quelques personnes
trouvèrent pourrait le penser en tout
cas il ya beaucoup d'engagement de la
part des personnels pour faire en sorte
que les conditions des tensions soient
les moins une possible moi je ne doute
pas que le personnel soit dédié
évidemment à ce que ça aille mieux et
tout le monde le souhaite mais on parle
bien d'une prison dans laquelle il ya
des rats des punaises de lit a écouté un
vrai plan de lutte a été mis en place
depuis plus de deux ans maintenant
l'établissement on a des les sociétés
qui passe pour la dératisation pour la
lutte contre les punaises les cafards
trois fois par semaine dans
l'établissement donc on voit bien que
c'est un sujet qui a été pris à bras le
corps et qui quand même moins pression
que qu'il a pu être il ya 2 3 ans en
arrière
mais quand vous arrivez vous dans cette
prison c'est ce à quoi vous avez à faire
en fait c'est j'imagine qu'on n'ait pas
nommé directeur de fresnes
si on est le plus beau le plus mauvais
élève de la classe
oui on sait c'est un peu
un pied-de-nez un bienne et au passé
j'ai commencé ma carrière comme il est
surveillant dans cet établissement en
1988 donc c'est un peu un retour aux
sources
c'est à fresnes et vous le disais tout à
l'heure qui a le plus haut taux de
surpopulation
combien à combien sont des détenus par
cellule alors à fresnes
on avait alors friends and evolution les
cellules sont assez grandes
combien de mètres carrés ont déçu on est
sur à peu près à aller sur dix 11 mètres
carrés par cellule et où on avait
tendance à avoir des cellules triples et
l'or aujourd'hui la crise sanitaire
passant par là et avec l'engagement et
l'implication de tous les magistrats
d'application des peines
on n'a plus du tout aucune cellule
triplé puisqu'on a perdu près de 400
détenus en quelques en quelques semaines
sur sur la structure ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a 450 détenus qui sont
en cellule individuelle et qui n'était
pas le cas auparavant sur fresnes le
reste des personnes sont sont à deux là
où elle était à 3 qu'on est dans des
conditions sanitaires à peu plus adapté
le confinement dans l'enfermement c'est
difficile on l'a compris la promiscuité
elle est dans les cellules mais elle est
également dans les parloirs et moi j'ai
vu pour la première fois une promenade
je sais pas pourquoi ils appellent ça
une promenade c'est en fait un couloir
de béton en fait on a une multitude de
petites cours de promenade qui
aujourd'hui nous permet de sortir près
de 200 détenus sur un sur un samedi ou
s'ils ont un dimanche dans une course
comme ça aujourd'hui on est à peu près
une quinzaine de personnes détenues il
ya une cour de cours de promenade fait
60 mètres carrés j'avais plus de crainte
en tout cas sur la l'interruption des
parloirs
oui que le dispositif de cours de
promenade qui est plutôt bien bien admis
à prennent pas toujours le connais les
personnes le connaissent et ça
fonctionne et ça permet de bien réguler
les mouvements justement ne pas voir
trop de monde en même temps parce que si
vous avez une trop grande pour les gens
se rassemblent alors que dans une petite
course est plus facile aussi de rappeler
les consignes sanitaires arrive à
remonter à paris ça arrive
en dordogne où des convois un proche ou
encore vers lui c'est vrai donc pourquoi
ça ne serait pas vrai à l'intérieur
comme à des malades chez vous à fresnes
du coc vide
fred a été le premier établissement en
fait français au sein duquel le virus
s'est répandu puisqu'on a eu le premier
détenu qui a été contaminé on a eu du
personnel médical qui à un moment donné
c'est retour est malade on a été le
premier site à mettre un dispositif
d'isolement où on a placé des
personnalités qui auraient pu être en
contact avec 62 personnes
finalement on peut dire que pour
l'instant le virus est vraiment contenu
bas on est aujourd'hui il doit nous
rester une seule personne détenue malade
voire deux dans cet établissement alors
qu'on aurait pu penser qu'ils aient
l'épidémie qui vraiment en raison de la
promiscuité à fresnes galles mais pour
le moment en tout cas tout ça est très
bien et est très connu on sent le poids
de l'histoire dans cette prison tous
racontent la date de création il ya du
parquet je vois les meubles derrière
vous qui date de la création où on
rappelle en 1898 je vois des des
horloges
est-ce que vous avez un objet privé
quelque chose qui parle de vous dans
votre bureau à au jeune jeannot jet
privé je vais papier à côté de moi mais
je peux aller chercher si vous voulez
aller oui aller le chercher bien sûr
qu'est ce que c'est la balance de la
justice c'est tout un symbole donc cette
balance pas me suis dans la différer
dans les différents établissements que
je dirige je pense qu'effectivement elle
représente bien ce qu'est ce qu'est la
justice
symbole de la balance de la justice et
je pense que quel que soit le le rôle
qu'on tient dans un établissement
pénitentiaire
l'importance et c'est la droite eu en
fait et c'est ce qu'on rappelle souvent
nos agents d'encadrement à nos officiers
c'est d'être droit c'est à dire que dès
lors que on promet quelque chose à une
personne convient même si j'ai des
personnes des tubes il faut qu'on tienne
parole et c'est ce symbole de la balance
de la justice à mon avis et c'est ce qui
le représente le mieux quand vous vous
êtes déplacé tout à l'heure pour aller
chercher votre balance
on a entendu ce bruit qui est très
particulier à fresnes
ce bruit du parquet qui grincent et en
fait ce parquet il est dans la prison un
peu partout et ça fait sa singularité
c'est vrai que c'est assez unique c'est
le seul établissement en tout cas que je
connaisse qui était en est dotée en tout
cas de cette taille
vous avez ce fameux grand couloir de 250
mètres qui vous emmène en tout cas
depuis la grille d'entrée
en détention et qui vous montre jusqu'à
la chapelle qui est à 250 mètres plus
haut toutes les personnes détenues passe
sur ce parquet donc c'est le signe d'une
entrée en prison mais c'est aussi le
signe d'une libération
parce qu'en général quand on emprunte ce
parquet pour diriger vers le greffe avec
ces affaires c'est qu'on est proche de
la sortie et je pense que j'ai aussi
tout symbole là merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci infiniment
cette semaine c'est un poète un tendre
qui nous lit vos paroles de l'ombre lui
ozon par un zinzin
enfin saint-etienne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut des confiné salut lire pour en
sortir salut maitena jeu mais plutôt
comme ça que comme ça que je me suis
rasé tout seul le point de presse demain
et j'ai fait un trou et c'est mon chat
c'est une fiche de lecture du petit
prince que je vous lis avec plaisir je
viens de relire pour la deuxième fois en
prison et pour la quatrième fois de ma
vie ce très beau récit j'ai également vu
le film bon qui brode un peu trop à mon
goût mais j'ai surtout grandi avec le
disque vinyle et du début des années 70
je suis d'un autre siècle
quand je les rues et à chaque fois je me
suis rendu compte que je ne connaissais
pratiquement parker finalement il a
toujours été à mes côtés ce petit prince
et cette très belle phrase on ne voit
bien qu'avec le coeur l'essentiel est
invisible pour les yeux a toujours été
comme un credo pour moi j'ai toujours
fonctionné avec le coeur si bien que
j'ai souvent ignorer la raison et ce
monde ne fonctionne pas avec le coeur il
faut raison garder oui mais c'est si
beau de rêver et de savoir qu'on a
quelqu'un quelque part qui compte sur
vous c'est pas ça la vie c'est tellement
mystérieux le pays des larmes ça c'est
un moment très émouvant pour moi j'ai
beaucoup pleuré
surtout lorsqu'il perd le renard et
quand il s'en va tout doucement encore
lorsque j'écris ces mots l'émotion le
submergé j'ai les larmes aux yeux je
suis trop sentimental les trophées
motive ça me perdra ah ben voilà
sam a perdu j'ai les deux pieds dedans
il faut assumer alors j'assume
difficilement et je vis et ce livre est
magnifique et pure c'est une bouffée
d'air frais cette histoire est un peu
mon histoire mais le bouton 1 an gemma
rose et même si j'ai un ami renard je
n'ai plus des toiles ou retourner merci
beaucoup pour ce livre qui à ravir et
ravivé le souvenir de mon enfance
heureuse de quand j'étais encore
innocente
les illustrations sont vraiment très
belle celui là je le garde avec moi je
ne donne pas à la bibliothèque
[Applaudissements]
la femme que vous allez entendre
maintenant vous ne la connaissez
peut-être pas et pourtant si vous êtes
une personne détenue
c'est une femme qui est unique et
essentielle dans votre vie elle est la
seule personne à pouvoir rentrer et où
elle veut quand elle veut
dans n'importe quelle prison en france
son job c'est contrôleur des lieux de
privation de liberté à l'intérieur
[Musique]
là
j'étais victime du bâtiment b au
rez-de-chaussée
bah dites vous une trentaine de
personnes coûteront une personne seule
que ce que je vais faire je peux rien y
faire
cependant des rondes rester dans la
course ensuite dans la cour de promenade
et les surveillants il est l homme et
ses enfants ils ont laissé la porte
ouverte
il était là il se dotera de regarder et
j'aurais dit leur souris en souriant et
gauche d'être à terre mais en interne et
j'ai pas essayé
c'est le moment qu ils sont venus et
c'était déjà trop tard et que je régime
ont déjà tous passé que j'ai faits
portent plate et de mon département
porte est plate et j'ai demandé de
manger intérêts nous sommes regardés
jouer tous pourris j'ai même quand je la
chemempa quand il est propre en fait tu
sais pas tu sais pas loties fumât côté
ça vient du mot les trous yellow et un
trou si paris l'autre côté tout ce qu'il
fait comme cuisine s'arrête ici
je sais qu est-ce qui cuisinent le soir
et même quand il parle voir quand il
parle aussi je les entends
je vois pas pourquoi ce quartier entre
parenthèses respect ils ont droit la
douche tous les jours et puis il ya des
gens ici ben il on n'a pas la douche
tous les jours non non je suis revenu à
l'essai il faut je me réinscrire à la
bibliothèque pour pouvoir aller à la
bibliothèque ça c'est mal fait aussi
bien côté au sport tu changes de
bâtiments faudrait inscrire à chaque
fois alors s'il ya pas de place adage en
interview je dis bonjour à linazay
bonjour comment se passe le confinement
écoutez comme tout le monde c'est à dire
difficile mais on fait quand même partie
des privilégiés par rapport aux
soignants aux caissières et c'est donc
on va pas se plaindre mais c'est
difficile d'organiser le travail dans
ces conditions on vient de voir quelques
images d'un documentaire qui n'a pas
d'ailleurs encore été diffusée sur lcp
qu'on verra sous peu est-ce que ce qu'on
a vu et fidèle est ce que vous voyez est
ce que c'est kafka la prison oui c'est
vraiment un milieu extrêmement difficile
particulièrement dans les maisons
derrière c'est difficile pour tout le
monde parce que c'est une privation de
la liberté de circulation mais
malheureusement dans la situation
actuelle des prisons ça n'est pas que la
privation de liberté de circulation
c'est aussi la privation de tous les
droits finalement le droit à la santé le
droit au maintien des liens familiaux
tout ça ne peut pas se faire dans des
conditions satisfaisantes du fait de la
surpopulation qui est vraiment le fléau
de la situation carcérale en france
la surpopulation c'est ce qui attire en
prison ah oui c'est ce qui est pire pour
nous sommes un des pays d'ailleurs cette
surpopulation est la plus importante au
point d'ailleurs que la france a été
condamné le 30 janvier c'est lassant par
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pour sa surpopulation carcérale
ce que vous nous dites adeline hazan
c'est que la privation de liberté ça ne
doit pas être la privation de la dignité
non c'est ça la privation de liberté ça
doit être la privation de la liberté de
circulation les personnes soit été
condamnés soit ne le sont pas il ya
quand même 22 mille détenus sur les 71
milles en temps normal qu'ils sont des
détenus provisoires c'est à dire qu'ils
n'ont pas été jugés et qui donc de ce
fait là
son présumé innocent et ceux là sont
justement dans ces maisons d'arrêt dont
je parlais où la situation de la
détention est la pire
donc là on est vraiment dans des
atteintes au droit manifestes et dans
des atteintes aux droits récurrente
c'est ce que avec mon équipe depuis six
ans dénonçant régulièrement et nous
faisons également bien sûr des
propositions pour endiguer cette
surpopulation carcérale et vous savez
beaucoup de français s'inquiètent de
savoir des criminels dehors avec sa
libération préventive
moi je pense qu elle allait plus loin la
garde des sceaux a demandé aux
magistrats que soit libéré les détenus
qui étaient à moins de deux mois ou deux
mois de leur fin de peine
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que des gens qui seraient sortis toute
façon au mois de juin vont sortir un
mois ou deux mois avant il n'y a pas
plus de risque de les faire sortir
maintenant que dans deux mois et
justement ça pose la question ça de la
fonction de la prison la prison ça doit
être c'est même une loi pénitentiaire de
2009 qui le rappelle ça doit être
d'abord une façon de permettre aux
condamnés de se réinsérer dans la
société
donc c'est bien de cela dont il s'agit
malheureusement compte tenu de cette
surpopulation endémique que je dénonce
et bien et compte tenu du trop faible
impact budgétaire qu'on a mis dans la
prison la peine de prison ne peut pas
suffisamment joué son rôle de
réinsertion mais en tout cas c'est de
cela qu'il s'agit
donc il ne s'agit pas de garder les gens
le plus longtemps possible ça n'a pas de
sens on sait par ailleurs que moins la
préparation de la sortie sera fait plus
il y aura de risques de récidive donc
moi je dis très souvent mettons les
moyens sur les prisons et moyens ça a
été augmentée d'ailleurs par ce
gouvernement
mais mettons les moyens nécessaires pour
que enfin quand il y a impossibilité de
faire autrement qu'à prison et bien
cette peine de prison au moins elles ne
servent pas qu'à éloigner davantage le
détenu de la société à le mettre encore
plus sur les côtés mais qu'au moins elle
sert à lui 2
n'est plus de chance pour la réinsertion
on n'en est malheureusement pas là parmi
les huit mille cinq cents détenus qui
ont été libérés il ya 130 130 détenus de
radicaliser dont des gens qui ont été
condamnés
d'après vos confrères du point pour des
faits de terrorisme et je voulais aussi
dire que cette politique est une pure
folie et qu'elle aura évidemment des
conséquences dramatiques
demain jordan bardella disait ces
derniers jours jordan bardella qui
appartient au rassemblement national
disait que des terroristes était libérée
c'est vrai nom c'est totalement faux le
il a été par la garde des sceaux exclut
immédiatement de cette possibilité de
libérer à à deux mois deux mois avant la
fin de la peine a été exclut
immédiatement les infractions en matière
de terrorisme et les infractions en
matière de violences intrafamiliales
donc ça n'est pas possible et s'il ya
peut-être je n'en sais rien mais je n'ai
même pas prouvé les disons s'il y a
quelques détenus terroristes qui sont
sortis c'est parce qu'il devait sortir
mais aucun détenu terroriste n'est
sortie en fonction des mesures qui ont
été prises compte tenu de cette crise
c'est totalement faux une question à
propos du confinement dans l'enfermement
adeline hazan à propos du téléphone vous
êtes fâchés combat propos du téléphone
oui oui je suis fâché parce que déjà en
temps normal il n'y pas suffisamment
accès au téléphone
et là quelle est la mesure qui a été
prise par la garde des sceaux c'est
d'accorder un crédit de 40 euros sur
chaque compte téléphonique des détenus
faut savoir également que les détenus
peuvent téléphoner mais seulement sur
les courts si ou dans les cours de
promenade
heureusement il ya maintenant une
réforme qui fait mais elle n'est pas
encore déroulé jusqu'à son terme qui
fait que dans certaines prisons et il y
a un téléphone mural dans les cellules
mais dans la plupart des prisons encore
malheureusement les détenus doivent
sortir en cours de promenade dans les
coursives pour téléphoner à quelques
heures seulement et donc pas le soir par
exemple puisque ça se termine à 17 ou 18
aces et bay en fuite et c'est payant
bien sûr à lorsque la garde des sceaux a
ordonné c'est un crédit un crédit de 40
euros sur le compte de tous les détenus
mais 40 euros quand on sait que la
plupart maintenant d'entre nous les
détenus comme les
autre quand il appelle quelqu'un c'est
sur un portable ça fait environ 4 à 5
heures de communication dans la mesure
où les parloirs ont été totalement
suspendu ce qu'on peut évidemment
comprendre compte tenu de la crise
sanitaire
je pense qu'il aurait fallu faire comme
elle l'a fait pour la télévision
c'est à dire rendre le téléphone gratuit
pendant cette crise sanitaire ça me
semble absolument évident qu'est ce
qu'on vous souhaite pour la fin du
confinement adeline hazan d'arriver à
convaincre d'arriver à convaincre et
l'opinion publique et les pouvoirs
publics que en ce qui concerne les
prisons il faut on ne peut plus rester
en france avec une situation carcérale
aussi désastreuse aussi compliqué aussi
contraire à la dignité de la personne et
la dignité de la personne c'est au delà
de l'ensemble des droits fondamentaux
c'est quelque chose sur le sur lequel on
ne peut pas transiger
merci beaucoup a dit la nasa merci les
aga règne avec nous bonne fin de
confinement merci infiniment
i au revoir
[Applaudissements]
du sport du sport qui fait peur du sport
de compétition
quatre fois champion du monde de kick
boxing c'est trop dur cyril peine bien
qu and tu peux me dire bonjour à tous
ces scieries balzac n je suis cinq fois
champion du monde de kick boxing et
champion du monde en titre et je vais
vous montrer aujourd'hui quelques
exercices pour un peu et bien être bien
dans votre peau
et comme on dit un esprit sain dans un
corps dans un corps sain et ces
exercices qui vont un peu vous aider à
vous évaluer votre quotidien
car je pense qu'avoir une activité
physique au quotidien eh bien ça nous
permet de se sentir mieux
donc je vais vous donner ma routine en
tout cas mon échauffement du quotidien
que vous pouvez appliquer comme une
vraie séance à part entière alors on
part tout simplement dans cette position
vous êtes debout on prépare avec pony
donc je sautille d'un pied à l'autre
comme ça pendant un peu près tout le
monde
je vais mettre en position de garde pied
gauche devant pied droit derrière et je
vais soucier et m une simulation de
dialectes du bras 1-2 hop hop hop 50
fois je passe mes pieds parallèles et je
vais descendre en position de squats
je descends et quand je remonte crochet
et je puis vote sur mon pied je descends
crochet une fois qu'on a récupéré on
passe sur le rhum 2 pour le rang 2 on
repart dans la même dynamique donc ont
pillé un bon pied gauche pierre hier en
position de fond et je vais mettre mon
bras tendu comme ça et un gainage et hop
je saute et je change de direction et je
reste zen et hop une fois que vous avez
vu ce mouvement là vous allez maintenant
mettre vos mains derrière vos oreilles
et venir en contact avec le genou et le
coude opposé comme ça
si hop hop hop hop et cette fois-ci
houleux de faire venir toucher votre
coude à votre genou vous allez faire
venir toucher votre main avec votre pied
comme ceux-ci hop hop
alors c'est pas grave si on touche pas
vous voyez moi je touche pas forcément
hommes hop hop ou 50 fois ok up pour se
voir en 3 on va repartir sur un premier
mouvement que vous connaissez déjà qui
est celui ci 1 2 3 à 50 fois à georges
de côté 50 fois et ensuite qu'on attend
a fait ce mouvement là on passe au
beurre peas
je vais au salon je remonte 1 2 comme ce
moment il vous difficile
exceptionnellement on n'en fera pas 50
mais on en fera 25
une fois que vous avez fait ce mouvement
là vous allez entendre votre jambe et
soucis et sur la jambe d'appui d'accord
et ensuite vous allez changer de côté or
comme ceux ci on change de côté on
souffle un de voiliers moi-même savez
souffle donc premier mouvement d'abdos
je vais partir au sol comme ceci est à
chaque fois que je remonte je vais
tourner pour faire travailler les
obliques et faire une simulation de
direct comme cela hop je descends et
j'allonge membres a ensuite une fois que
vous avez fait ce mouvement là on va
lever les pieds du sol et tourner comme
ceux ci et venir en contact avec mon
coude encore est en jeu nous sommes
comme la au vent tout à l'heure hop hop
on va encore une fois venir mettre en
contact notre coude et notre jeu nous de
manière à garder une activité cardio hop
on va maintenant finir sur l'exercice du
boxeur très simplement qui est le
gainage donc je vais me mettre sur les
coudes comme ceci et je vais passer des
coudes aux mains hop hop 50 fois pop up
c'était une séance qui mêlait à la voix
entretien musculaire et cardio parce que
en kick boxing et bien comme sur un ring
j'ai besoin d'avoir un bon rythme
cardiaque mais à la fois un tonus
musculaire
j'espère que vous arriverez au bout et
je vous souhaite bon courage pour votre
confinement
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine à l'assemblée nationale a
eu lieu une audition intitulée impact
gestion et conséquences de l'épidémie de
coronavirus madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
était donc auditionné une audition en
visioconférence et on s'est dit que vous
auriez aimé savoir de quoi ça parlait du
coup on va appeler un député qui a
interpellé la ministre
bonjour stéphane peu bonjour vous allez
bien comment se passe votre consigne
mans bat ça va ça va je sais de
respecter le confirme en tout temps on
ayant en essayant de satisfaire les
obligations dans la circonscription la
seine saint denis a été particulièrement
touché par par le virus et donc il faut
aussi être aux côtés de tous ceux qui
qui sont debout qui se retroussent les
manches pour pour faire face et ils sont
nombreux ici
alors vous êtes député communiste de
seine-saint-denis et vous étiez nombre
dans l'hémicycle pendant l'audition de
madame b doublait sur les conditions de
détention actuelle avec l'ensemble du
jeu est une question c'est un peu
l'audition prison elle se faisait dans
le cadre du travail du gouvernement sur
la gestion du coc vide
oui oui parce que vous savez on est
depuis depuis maintenant la mi mars dans
un état d'urgence
état d'urgence sanitaire et vous savez
le problème des période d'état d'urgence
elles peuvent être nécessaires pour
faire face à une pandémie comme on a
notre pays à faire actuellement mais en
même temps il ya beaucoup de risques de
voir quelques principes de droit des
libertés fondamentales être un peu mise
à mal donc c'est sait il ce d'autant que
cet état d'urgence va être longue
puisque la loi donne donne les pleins
pouvoirs à l'exécutif pendant deux mois
reconductible ont ensuite chaque mois
donc c'est des périodes jamais vu dans
l'histoire de notre pays en matière
d'état d'urgence
enfin la dernière fois c'était en 1900
par la première loi qui a instauré
l'état d'urgence un paysan 1955 pendant
la guerre d'algérie et c'était des d
état d'urgence qui était accordée à
l'exécutif pour des périodes de douze
jours renouvelable par le parlement tous
les 12 juin
vous voyez que on est et ses
gouvernements l'exécutif c'est le
gouvernement donc donc donc il faut
faire attention beaucoup d'associations
d'avocats de juges de magistrats
s'inquiètent un peu de de l'état de
droit dans notre pays qui est quand même
un trait de l'identité française d'être
un pays où les libertés fondamentales
sont assurées quelle que soit quels que
soient les périodes mais en fait ce que
j'aimerais savoir stéphane peu celle ci
vous nous dites ça parce que vous êtes
communiste est que nicole belloubet elle
est la république en marche ou parce que
vraiment il ya des choses qui vous
mettre la puce à l'oreille
bah écoutez quand on supprime quand on
supprime les parloirs qu'on dit qu'on
voit là des désemplir les prisons est ce
qui est un peu le cas mais que par
ailleurs on autorise sans décision de
justice de prolonger la détention
provisoire
vous y voyez pas un paradoxe il n'y a
pas de postures politiciennes mais on
peut pas à la fois dire on va désormais
aller prison parce que ça peut être des
clusters potentiel pour le coc vide 19
et en même temps dire on va prolonger
sans mesure de justice les détention
provisoire pour des gens qui je le
rappelle quand on est en détention
provisoire on n'est pas jugée donc on
est présumé innocent donc il est si vous
voulez ya quand même des des messages
contradictoires moi je ne je n'ai pas de
position hostiles d'elle parce que le
gouvernement sort est en marche
j'observe les situations concrètes
je pose des questions concrètes et
parfois jeu quand je n'ai pas de réponse
je m'en inquiète et parfois je proteste
c'est le cas soit la détention
provisoire enfin je crois vous avez un
livre à nous conseiller stéphane peu oui
oui parce que c'est un petit moment à
mon manque qu'il faut mettre à profit
pour un peu réfléchir alors j'ai proposé
ce petit lille il fait moins de 20 pages
c'est indignez vous de stéphane hessel
c'est un peu un livre testament il l'a
écrit il avait 93 ans il a été résistant
il a été déporté à buchenwald il s'en
évader il a ensuite participé à la
rédaction de la déclaration des droits
de l'homme de 1948
c'est un grand monsieur qui a 93 ans
était encore très jeune dans sa tête et
dans ce petit livre d'une vingtaine de
pages qui sont un petit livre testament
il explique bien que la digne à sion et
sans indignation on à de l'indifférence
avec l'indifférence on a beaucoup de
désespoir et que l'indignation est
peut-être là le premier le premier
sentiment qui nous permet de réfléchir
de se lever et d'espérer et je trouve
qu'en cette période
ces vingt petites pages sont utiles et
précieuse à lire et bien grâce à vous
stéphane peu indignez vous de stéphane
hessel comme tous les autres livres qui
ont été qui seront cités dans cette
émission seront distribués grâce à lire
pour en sortir à la prison de fresnes
dans l'est dans les jours qui suivent la
diffusion de l'émission merci beaucoup
stéphane peu merci infiniment au reste à
l'assemblée avec un conseil de lecture
gédéon nom revient gédéon reste à
l'assemblée qu'un conseil de lecture
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle le philippe
gosselin je suis député les républicains
de la manche c'est en normandie
je suis vice président de la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale qui
s'occupe plus particulièrement des
questions de justice et des questions
pénitentiaires
c'est ce qui m'a motivé pour être à vos
côtés d'une certaine façon aujourd'hui
en cette période très particulière du
coc vide 19 voulez vous vous assurez
l'ensemble des personnels pénitentiaires
mais aussi bien sur l'ensemble des
prisonniers de toutes celles et tous
ceux qui travaillent en ce moment dans
des établissements comme ceux où vous
êtes vous assurer de mes pensées et puis
surtout je voulais vous communiquer mon
envie de lire un super livre qui a été
écrit par joseph joffo ça s'appelle un
sac de billes un sac de billes je les
lui quand je suis arrivé en sixième
quand je suis devenue pensionnaire et je
vivais ça le pensionnat comme une
privation de liberté rien à voir avec la
vôtre mais ça me rappelle un petit
quelque chose ce bouquin il est plein
d'espoir il est drôle il raconte même si
le début n'est pas drôle du tout il
raconte l'histoire d'une famille juive
qui est parti du xviiie dans paris et
qui a dû fuir l'avancée des allemands et
puis le port de l'étoile jaune
cette famille la famille joffo elle a su
réagir pour que ces enfants partent se
protéger se mettre aux abris ils sont
passés par la ligne de démarcation
ils se sont retrouvés à nice à marseille
en savoie
bref ça a été une sacrée épopée est dans
ce livre il y a de l'humour sur la ligne
de démarcation on arrive à avoir joseph
et son frère maurice qui font du trafic
avec les soldats allemands
les soldats italiens tous appareils le
complètement incroyable c'est plein
d'espoir et voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui
alors qu'on a une période très trouble
troublé il faut lire ce livre qui nous
fait réfléchir qui nous rappellent les
heures sombres mais qui nous rappelle
aussi qu'à la fin il ya toujours de
l'espoir l'espoir de se retrouver
l'espoir d'aller vers un avenir meilleur
et ça c'est un magnifique message
positif bien la musique
évidemment ça compte pour tout le monde
partout tout le temps alors qu'ils vous
offre le live de la semaine
le garçon qui a fait sa mythique film la
haine
l'important ce n'est pas la chute c'est
l'atterrissage il prépare en ce moment
même la comédie musicale autour de la
haine marre et jude voir ça et donc
alors live de la semaine signée par
quatre killer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ce message à tous ceux qui sont
enfermés toi tu fais je sais que c'est
une galère de ouf je sais que quand il
fait beau déjà en temps normal on n'a
pas l'impression de de base de faire ce
qu'on veut
moi c'est des temps durs en vrai il faut
simplement essayé de se dire que rené
tous logés à la même enseigne sauf que
vous vous êtes encore plus désordre mais
en même temps c'est normal il faut il
faut avancer
donc là je n'ai pas la faire essayer de
faire au mieux pour vous montrer
l'exemple et ou en même temps t'as vu
c'est très évident à dire mais lâchez
pas la faire
quoi qu'il arrive maintenant à la sortie
il va falloir quoi qu'il arrive
charbonné de poufs pour se remettre en
ordre
donc force à vous et un gros big up à
tous ceux qui sont en faire leur sale
toi même tu sais que tu leur fais
[Musique]
m
il revient dans ma mémoire le chemin de
l'école des romances sans parole en
premier lieu chansons d'autrefois on
oublie douce france
cher pays de mon enfance des cliniques
la france une histoire sirois et 7 18
mois six mois
parti de rien on arrive à ce que
visez-vous qu'on apprend rien qui nous
aide c'est souvent rien ce camp vise il
dit souvent qu on est des bons à rien
suffit d'un rien pour qu'on y croit
quoi qu'en dise quoiqu'on en dise
quoiqu'on en dise quoiqu'on en dise nous
devons pas perdre notre dame ouest
physique tandis parti de rien on va
trouver la sortie tandis et pour tous
ceux qui ont pour nous d'une miroiterie
hollande notaire avant qu'oscar this
irak tandis ça fait un bout de temps que
les partis ça ferait un bout de pain pas
depuis tout le temps dans ses coudes en
aura du mal à terre sans manches de
parmesan dimanche j'attends patiemment
mais je n'ai pas de doute la vie
[Musique]
un coffret pour le char vos rides
que j'aime pas les méchants pour le sale
construit au point g qui cacheront pour
le communiqué j'aime le rappeler
et justin mapp morning je pète les
plombs
[Musique]
c'est mon job
[Applaudissements]
il a deux étoiles au michelin mais avant
d'en arriver là où il en a fait du
chemin
après sa galette de maïs ou l'oeuf
mollet dans la soupe à l'oignon voici
qu'arrive la recette de risotto de pâtes
avec son corps de biff oui thierry marx
[Applaudissements]
bonjour thierry marx aujourd'hui un plat
à moins de trois euros et avec la liste
cantine à bhl en détention là on part
pour un grand classique des tensions les
pattes corned beef pulpe de tomate ou
concentré de tomate coquillettes haye le
morceau de nyon où j'ai gardé de la
précédente recettes et le petit morceau
poireau que j'ai gardés de la précédente
trois sets et avec tout ça on va faire
des coquillettes façon risotto première
chose on va ouvrir la boîte de corn beef
voilà je le mets de côté va prendre
oignons jeu cisaille un peu j'ai mes
oignons
maintenant je vais faire la même chose
avec le poireau couper finement l'ail je
vais pas embêtés je vais juste l'écraser
avec la peau voilà un petit peu d'huile
a laissé tout doucement monter en
température
alors je mets bien là et d'un côté pour
qu'elle diffuse et que je puisse la
retrouver très facilement dans ma
préparation pour pouvoir la retirer aux
deux tiers de la cuisson maintenant les
coquillettes
il en faut 50 grammes par personne
environ dépend de votre votre appétit et
je vais faire comme si je faisais un
risotto rajouter un petit peu de
matières grasses
je vais ajouter ma pulpe de tomate
alors on en tombe bien le bruit
et jean robe et je vais ajouter une
petite goutte d'eau
je baisse légèrement la température je
crois un petit morceau de poivrons c'est
pas la peine d'utiliser tout le poids
mon on peut le garder pour une autre
préparation j'ai besoin de quelques
lanières
je vais tailler et mon petit mijoter est
parti on va couper le camp de b en gros
cubes
on va les laisser reposer on va changer
de poils le faire rissoler d'abord ça a
donné un peu de croustillant et moi le
hacker c'est quand même plus agréable
que de manger brut comme ça et je vais
préparer une toute petite persillade
je vais récupérer mon petit morceau die
ici que je vais venir
haché avec un petit peu de persil meco
qui est son père
voilà on est généreux il ya largement je
vais ajouter le corner de biff la petite
persillade qui va bien là on a un
risotto de coquillettes corned-beef prix
total du plat 2 euros 20
ça vous voyez c'est un vrai plan de télé
voilà comme à la télé la télé d'ailleurs
elle est arrivée en prison en 1975 au
début c'était dans les salles
collectives et puis dix ans plus tard
elle arrive dans les cellules grâce à
qui grâce à robert badinter le garde des
sceaux
merci qui merci robert alors chaque
semaine on regarde l'une archives de
télévision l'interview mythique d'un
écrivain dans l'émission apostrophes et
avant qu'on retrouve bernard pivot vous
avez rencontré une femme extraordinaire
elle est exceptionnelle elle va à son
rythme vraiment marguerite duras une
femme libre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la main nous sommes à nous sommes
assaillis yo entre les deux guerres les
années 20 vous avez quinze ans et demi
et vous êtes sur un bac qui traversent
le fleuve c'est à dire le mékong et vous
êtes drôlement hâtif et vous voulez pas
vous êtes actif et comment aborder nîmes
j'ai un chapeau d'homme
en fait oui un feutre aux couleurs bois
de rose ont large ruban noir et au pied
j'ai eu sa poule
vraiment je les ai eus au piéger des
lamés or des sujets deux pour danser
c'est vraiment sur le bac évidemment
vous devez faire un doigt vous remarqué
aujourd'hui on vous remarquerez à peine
c'est une mode qui se porte court à
manger jeune fille oui allez c'est vrai
aujourd'hui vous remarquerez pas mais à
cette époque on vous remarque est
d'ailleurs quelqu'un vous a remarqué qui
dans une grande limousine noire mais
vous regards se croisent et on peut dire
est ce qu'on peut dire que cet échange
de regard a changé votre vie oui alors
qu'ils vous regardent peut-être chinois
très riche mais vous le savez pas qui
dirigea son jeu qui je le sais à
l'automobile et puis au chauffeur je
sais les choses comme ça il a 12 ans
puisque vous j'ai 15 ans il a 27 ans vie
et vous savez on a l'impression que vous
savez qui va devenir votre ami votre
premier roman tout de suite dire que je
suis après qu'il ne m'avait pas des plus
jolies bacs et sur le moment je n'avais
pas d'avis sauf que j'étais assez étonné
par tous
kiraithe
deux milliardaires j'étais tout petit
et attirer ainsi sur ces situations que
j'aime bien votre livre que vous savez
dès le premier regard des six premiers à
vous échangez avec ce jeune chinois
qu'il va vous donner le plaisir vous
allez connaître avec lui le plaisir et
la jouissance
si vous venez dans le livre je lui dis
abandonné je le dis même sur le bak
devait déjà me plaisent je n'avais
jamais rencontrés je ne lui avais même
jamais parlé donc c'est assez étonnant
l'entretien parce que on voit on voit
bien que nous essayons de nous séduire
l'un l'autre
au début on est un peu méfiant je me
méfie un petit peu de sa rouerie et se
méfient un peu de mois de mars- de
schepper peut-être de deux de mes
questions de journalistes et et puis
finalement cette séduction marche bien
et puis je me souviens très bien aussi
j'avais du mal à me à me faire aux
silences de malades parce qu'elle ne
répond pas tout de suite à la question
il ya toujours une petite seconde comme
ça au où elle donne la réponse est
d'abord dans son cerveau et ensuite
c'est la réponse va sur sa langue
[Applaudissements]
alors à fresnes on peut prendre des
cours des cours de maths des cours de
sciences ou des cours de français et
s'étend entre autres aïcha baraka qui
donne ses cours
alors je la peine bonjour aïcha oui
bonjour bonjour comment se passe le
confinement mais petit tout va bien mais
s'adapte et on s'adapte assez vite
en fait vous travaillez pour l'éducation
nationale et vous êtes volontaire pour
aller travailler en prison
exactement c'est un choix tout à fait
c'est un choix une volonté personnelle
comme tous les membres de l'équipe en
fait vos élèves sont à quel niveau
d'études et ils ont quel âge aïcha alors
précisément la maison d'arrêt de fresnes
ya pas de quartiers mineurs
donc là je varie de 18 ans à 65 ans et
plus mais il nous est arrivé d'avoir des
élèves de plus de 70 ans encourt mes
origines apprendre quoi pourra notamment
se remettre à niveau faire effectuer des
tours de main entre suivre des cours de
physique simplement par park ou de choc
personnel a donc et ensuite l'engagement
de l'éducation nationale sur place c'est
d'effectuer des cours donc de donner des
cours de tous niveaux
donc deux français on voulait 10 mai
jusqu'aux études supérieures post-bac
inscrit également nos élèves à des
études supérieures des licences btsc
notamment des études avec le cnam pour
freiner cette année nous avons plus de
40 étudiants supérieur supérieur de
deuxième niveau 3e niveau vous avez quoi
licence maîtrise masters voilà c'est ça
tout à fait on a des licences on a des
maîtrises des licences ces barrières
résistance physique sciences de la vie
licence de droit les études du cnam donc
des personnes qui ont pu voir la
distance à distance voilà alors
dites-nous ce que c'est que l'article l7
121-1 du code de procédure pénale nous
donnons donc des attestations donc des
certificats de scolarité comme ça serait
fermée lycée ou au collège et ils
peuvent joindre ces certificats
scolarité à leur dossier de manière un
peu sollicité donc les avocats et
intégrée sardos il pourra voir des
réductions de peine
est ce que vous avez à faire de
l'analphabétisme aussi oui complètement
malheureusement
le taux d'illettrisme et analphabétisme
est très élevé en prison donc il atteint
quasiment les 10%
donc ce qui nous a poussés en faire
justement une priorité vous dites que
tout se joue au premier contact avec vos
élèves
oui tout à fait tout ce jour tous les
contacts c'est à dire que là c'est une
relation qui est assez particulière
c'est à dire qu'il ya une confiance qui
se met en place mais en même temps tout
en étant distant parce que finalement on
nie pas les lieux on pas qu'on travaille
en prison en mieux carcéral maintenant
il y il est en tout cas taillé pour tous
tous mes collègues c'est la même chose
c'est-à-dire à partir du moment où on a
une porte qui se ferme
on oublie et on avec des élèves on n'est
plus avec des tons j'imagine que dans
toutes les classes il ya les bons et les
mauvais élèves
sk les fayots aussi wigan tout cas de
tous il ya des failles où il a su chi
chi juste montfaucon du bruit et puis
qui voit là ils veulent sûrement
intéressant et puis il ya toujours ceux
qui connaissent tout sur tout et ce qui
finalement n'ont rien à apprendre mais
qui descendent quand même donc bien sûr
il ya de tout et il faut s'adapter et
c'est justement la richesse de notre
métier c est vous vous avez appris quoi
vos achats en enseignant en prison vous
avez appris quoi que tout est possible
finalement que tout est possible c'est
vrai que quand on est enseignant alors
ça on le sait et on donne les moyens en
tout cas à nos élèves mais quoi qu'il en
soit de voir quand même de très belles
réussites sortir j'ai envie de dire du
de ce milieu on dit que c'est quand même
c'est quand même assez beau parce que il
suffit parfois d'une phase d'un livre
d'un cours pour que pour que la personne
en face b se disent effectivement j'ai
cette possibilité j'ai cette chance et
elle apprend quelque chose
à partir de là tout peut changer il vous
manque vous élève
oui quand même le contact les klingons
aïcha j'en profite
donnez moi une seconde je rappelle à
ceux qui nous regardent si vous avez des
messages à faire passer à vos familles
puisque bien sûr les parloirs sont
supprimés n'hésitez pas à aller sur le
l'adresse que je vous donne vous pouvez
nous laisser des tweets des images des
vidéos ce que vous voulez et puis on
relaie la semaine prochaine c'est
déconfinement accueillir pour en sortir
point org déconfinement at lire pour en
sortir point org ou alors vous allez sur
twitter as tu des confiné et puis si
vous êtes détenus vous pouvez nous
écrire ce qui vous arrive en ce moment
quand vous êtes dans le confinement et
la détention pendant la crise du coc
vide
n'hésitez pas vous nous écrivez c'est le
trop vous nous écrivez at lcp sûrement
pas apte la grèce je vous la donne lcp
106 rue de l'université 75007 paris
merci beaucoup a eu l'air d'avoir été
avec nous l'an prix merci à vous merci
infiniment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu me surveille quelques infos du dedans
les images que vous voyez là ce sont des
détenus à rennes alors là c'est ta
rennes mais ça arrive aussi ailleurs et
c'est détenus fabriquent des masques
elles sont payées 4 euros de l'heure
évidemment on est bien loin du smic
comme promis des nouvelles des livres la
semaine dernière qui ont bien été livrés
à la prison de grenoble grâce à lire
pour s'en sortir et son réseau de
libraires indépendants voit les images
ci à des images on en est sûr on a la
preuve
enfin faites nous confiance
c'est l'association lire pour en sortir
qui s'en occupe en s'appuyant sur son
réseau de libraires indépendants
et puis je ne sais pas si vous en avez
entendu parler mais certains détenus ont
lancé des cagnottes pour aider les
soignants il lance des cagnottes qu'ils
abondent eux mêmes avec leur propre
argent
c'est arrivé entre autres à reims ou à
amiens où les détenus donc socothyd
reims a réuni 1060 8 euros et amiens 955
chapeau bas problème de cheveux ils
viennent vers une mule sors de ce corps
hulk
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
question vous vous posez bien sûr c'est
à qui allons nous donner le mot de la
fin
s'appelle tout de suite bonjour jérôme
kerviel
bonjour michael obi vraiment merci
d'être avec nous vous avez bien avec
vous nous on va bien comment se passe
votre confinement jérôme m'a écouté
paradoxalement j'essaie de positiver je
me dis que mon passé avec j'ai fait un
petit tour en prison à une époque et que
ce compliment me permet de relativiser
beaucoup de choses et je pense
évidemment à tous les détenus je sais ce
qu'ils sont en train de virer je pense
aussi aux surveillants et aux familles
des détenus qui ne peuvent pas aller
voir en ce moment 0 2 quand on vous a
contacté la première chose que vous
m'avez dit c est ce qu on vous parlait
des surveillants ouais parce que c'est
souvent les oubliées dans ce genre de
situation et eux ils sont aussi enfermé
et c'est tout aussi difficile pour eux
et souvent on n'y pense pas et j'ai une
pensée particulière pour eux aussi
évidemment pour tous les détenus parce
que je sais à quel point c'est compliqué
sur tout les parloirs sont annulés en ce
moment si j'ai bien compris
oui donc et que et que ça c'est le genre
de chose qui peut rendre fou parce que
le seul la salle fenêtre sur l'extérieur
quinqua détenu peut avoir c'est sa
famille ses proches et évidemment c'est
très compliqué pour eux mais faut pas
non plus oublier les surveillants de
percer le personnel pénitentiaire vous
vous en souvenez vous de nouveaux
surveillants
oui oui j'ai beaucoup appris à leur
contact et ils ont tous été vraiment
sympa et est très compréhensif et
traînant l'empathie et c'est souvent des
gens qui sont très décriée mais qu'il
faut un métier qui pas facile non plus
oui je vous étiez à l' isolement
mais j'étais effectivement seul en
cellule dans un quartier d'isolement
est-ce que c'était une chance 10
allemands c'est tout à la fois une
chance parce qu'on se sent une certaine
façon de protéger mais psychologiquement
c'est tout aussi compliqué parce
qu'effectivement il va solitude et
psychologiquement c'est de ce point de
vue là un petit peu plus dur parce qu'on
a très peu de contacts avec l'extérieur
et avec d'autres personnes
donc psychologiquement c'est plus
compliqué on est seul face à soi même
la majeure partie du temps et quelque
chose qui est vrai puisque le chemin
très très très chaud très chaud à gérer
au moins autour des bus alors est ce que
vous avez lu en détention jérôme kerviel
voilà par moment j'ai eu effectivement
notamment un livre qui m'avait été
offert par un mes amis je pensais que
c'était une blague
qu'est-ce qu'on manquait un peu de moi
il m'a offert cet homme d'à la recherche
du temps perdu
et effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
de prime abord ne serait pas venu à
l'idée est que je me suis mis dedans
j'ai un peut de toute façon compliqué
parce que c'est un peu aride par moments
mais mais c'est quelque chose qui m'a
fait énormément de bien à ce moment là
et vous l'avez lu en entier alors oui
j'avais que ça à faire donc oui oui j'ai
mis le temps mais je les bus est ce que
vous le recommander à ceux qui sont
détenus aujourd'hui web sur elle même
temps c'est là un formidable message
d'espoir ce que le gars du top 100 ont
retrouvé c'est ce qu'on espère tous
est-ce que les relations entre détenus
ça compte aussi
wait see tout heureux évidemment mais
j'imagine tout à la fois aussi que en ce
moment le confinement et le fait que les
gens soient bloqués dans leur cellule
majeure partie du temps du che du
confinement beaucoup pesé
psychologiquement également et je pense
qu'il doit y avoir de sacrées tension en
ce moment en cellule et façon plus plus
générale dans les maisons d'arrêt parce
que c'est comme on est comme en déduire
en cage dans ces cas là et tout cela
rend très pesant c'est difficile pour
vous de parler de cette période où elle
est parce qu on est en train de se
parler j'ai beaucoup d'image qui nous
reviennent mais en même temps je sais
aussi une façon pour moi de d'accepter
tout cela est de
[Musique]
de pouvoir prendre de la distance avec
avec cet événement là mais évidemment
c'est quelque chose
est-ce que jérôme kerviel la présence à
change un homme
ouais évidemment que ça change un homme
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'oublie pas
on apprend à vivre avec moi je vous
cache pas que je fais encore des
cauchemars à certains moments de cette
période là même si ça m'a appris
beaucoup beaucoup de choses que j'ai
fait également dans ce cadre à leur fait
notamment des survivants
certains détenus également de
formidables rencontres c'est un univers
qui est vraiment très très violent et
tant sur le plan psychologique que
physique
et c'est quelque chose qui qui marque
anomalies ou es ce que vous avez un
message pour ceux qui sont dedans
le chiffre est en soyez forts je sais
que c'est compliqué mais que la lumière
au bout du tunnel
merci jérôme qu'est ce qu'on vous
souhaite pour la fin du confinement
le boxeur termine vite qu'on puisse tous
au revoir
que ferez vous jérôme quand le
confinement sera terminé une bonne
bouffe les bios maroc merci beaucoup
jérôme kerviel alors livre que vient de
nous citer jérôme kerviel à la recherche
du temps perdu bien entendu il sera
livré comme tous les autres livres qui
ont été cités pendant cette émission 2d
confiné non à les envoyer à la prison de
fresnes
c'est l'association lire pour en sortir
qui va s'en charger en s'appuyant sur le
réseau de libraires indépendants autour
des prisons se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à 19h30 bien entendu d'ici là
il ya les rediffusions ou encore sur la
chaîne youtube vous tapez lcp il ya une
chaîne lcp sur youtube et vous pouvez
voir toutes les émissions
on se retrouve donc vendredi à 19h30
qu'on soit dedans au dehors pour des
confiné jeu des confine tu déconfit il
des coûts fine nous déconfit non je
pense aux infirmiers aux aides soignants
aux livreurs ok si aux personnes âgées
aux enfants et puis
j'ai pris sur moi j'ai pas envie de vous
faire peur pas vu colporter des rumeurs
il est plombé les moeurs j'ai beaucoup
trop trop dans la tête alors je rappe
très tard le soir juste le besoin
d'écrire des textes c'est ma façon mon
exutoire mais ne voulent m'ébranler part
je n'ai pas la prétention de vous conter
le bien du mal bien de vous donner des
leçons reçues juste irait dans l'armée
faisant mieux pour limiter des larmes
dans la main mais à distance elle
fonctionne nous cette si belle france
et ouais c'est chambre rester chez soi
mais a toujours pas s'occuper aura
bouquins et inscris toi fais du ménage
matin vers et profite de 100 % des
nouvelles de tes proches fait du sport à
la maison débarrasse toi de ta brille
surtout je vous en supplie ne sortait
que si nécessaire et bientôt je l'espère
retour à l'ordinaire